des pluies torrentielles
des glissements de terrain et des chants
entièrement inondé le sud de la colombie
britannique est frappé de plein fouet
par des intempéries dévastatrices
à moins de 100 km de là la ville de
mérite au coeur d'une région ravagée par
les feux de forêts cet été est
maintenant sous l'eau un ordre
d'évacuation a été émis pour tous les
résidents et plus de 7000 personnes
doivent maintenant trouver un toit
temporaire des centres ont été ouverts à
kelowna et kamloops pour recevoir ceux
qui ne peuvent pas se rendre chez des
proches
sur les routes la situation est
chaotique à la mi-journée le grand
vancouver et même coupée du reste du
pays par la route de nombreux axes
routiers de la province ont été fermées
à la circulation avec des centaines
d'automobilistes prise au piège
notamment à agassi dans la vallée du
fraser
ait des sauces à ce cocktail météo est
un événement exceptionnel et extrême les
pires inondations et glissements de
terrain depuis des décennies c'est
vraiment recevoir le mois de novembre en
entier dans 24 36 heures c'est à dire
c'est trois fois plus copieux on devrait
la voir et ça devrait être un des
boussoles beaucoup et le retour au calme
n'est pas pour tout de suite après ces
intempéries
le vent avec le risque de chutes
d'arbres et de pannes de courant alors
que déjà des dizaines de milliers de
foyers ont été privés d'électricité
au cours de la journée